[Musique]
début du procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 qui va durer près de neuf
mois le principal accusé salle abdeslam
est arrivé ce matin en fourgon la france
toute entière a été plongée dans
l'horreur
il y as avant cette date il y a après
cette date elles sont des centaines à
défier les talibans pour défendre leurs
leaders
le tout nouveau gouvernement a pourtant
l'intention d'appliquer la charia dans
le pays je répondrai à toutes les
questions sur ce qu'on est aimé décision
pendant cette nuit terrible je
répondrais aussi aux questions si elles
me sont posées sur ce qu'était nos
informations pourquoi tel ou tel
individu si je peux de sur les rails
éventuelles maintenant qu'on a libéré le
pays des envahisseurs on peut apporter
la charia la liberté la sécurité aux
afghans ces événements sont entrés par
effraction dans notre histoire est bien
sûr notre mémoire collective
il faut que la justice se soit au rendez
vous de ces événements le président du
tribunal lui demande de décliner son
identité et très vite le ton est donné
tout d'abord je tiens à témoigner qu'il
n'y a pas de divinité apparat là et que
mohammed est son messager le président
le rolland sur son travail j'ai délaissé
toute profession pour devenir un
combattant de l'état islamique dépasser
les combattants islamistes tirent en
l'air pour disperser la foule
des tirs de sommation mais aussi
certains qui ont visé des manifestants
deux personnes ont été tuées donc tout
ça est une débâcle une débâcle qui ne
fera pas simplement les états unis mais
d'une certaine façon toutes les forces
occidentales qui auront un moment agi en
afghanistan c'est à ce moment là que
salade et sam s'élever de lui-même
debout dans son box qui l'a interpellé
le président en le pointant du doigt en
lui expliquant que lui aussi je cite ces
propos était traité comme un chien il a
dénoncé ses conditions de détention très
strictes avant de menacer en quelque
sorte le président il doit dire
pourquoi il a commis ses actes s'il a
des regrets quelle était sa
participation et s'il le dit rien et
bien sa lâcheté sera encore plus grande
que celle que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
ils garderont ce jeu seul bien entendu
que ce procès soit une occasion de
comprendre de savoir et je souhaite
comme les victimes qu'ils parlent mais
j'ai des doutes sur le fait qu'ils le
feront les islamistes vont vouloir
montrer qu'ils ont toujours une capacité
d'action et je pense qu'ils vont vouloir
commettre un ou plusieurs actes
symboliques pas forcément contre les
lieux du procès qui sont vraiment très
bien sécurisé mais peut-être autour en
frappant des liens ou des personnes
sable des lieux ou des personnes
symboliques de la lutte antiterroriste
et évidemment des moments comme vous les
avez évoqué ceux des pros c'est lé
procès des attentats ou la la la la
pression médiatique politique et sur le
focus du de l'islamisme radical et de
son procès évidemment la menace est
encore plus élevé c'est pour ça que j'ai
réuni les préfets j'aurai des zones
donné instructions extrêmement clairs
notamment autour des lieux de culte
autour du lieu où se tiendra le procès
aussi avec trois filets de protection
autour de ce procès pour garantir la
sécurité il faut que la justice se
tiennent dans l'enseignement la sérénité
dans la sécurité on voit ce loup de ce
tigre de tasmanie alors il est ni
canidés ni félins c'est un marsupial
c'est comme un wallaby ou comme un
kangourou il ya une poche marsupial abri
l'autre procès du jour va se dérouler à
m le procès de cassandre fristot c'est
cette prof qui tenait une pancarte
antisémite dans une manif anti bastiani
terre début août il s'appelle benjamin
celui ci c'est un un des derniers le
dernier représentant de son espèce il
est mort en 1936 au zoo de vaud bart et
celui qui était allé le film et c'était
un célèbre naturaliste qui a été mordue
d'ailleurs pendant la prise de vue